this is a meeting of the digital culture
media and Sport select committee it's
part of our investigation into
misinformation and trusted voices we
have four Witnesses this morning thank
you all very much
coming we have David Dinsmore the chief
operating officer at news UK Alison
Phillips the editor of the Daily Mirror
Nick Hopkins the executive editor of
news at the guardian and Peter Wright
editor emeritus of DMG media in terms of
interests I suppose I should declare
that I used to work for the times a long
time ago so anyone else want to declare
any interests yeah I've written as a
freelancer for the guardian and I have
presented
um as a radio host of our for a talk
radio
anyone else
okay
um thank you um well let's let's sort of
start off
um and just to explain to our guests a
lot of the discussions we've been having
in this inquiry have been about uh
coverage both in newspapers and
broadcasting and online during the
pandemic when when clearly the
quality of news and information going
out was was genuinely a matter of life
and death for the whole country so that
was an area of great sensitivity so if I
can as it would go along the line left
to right
um who did your organization look to for
Reliable advice during the pandemic
yeah sorry
um good morning
so we would have
um
gone to a number of sources in in during
the pandemic I mean the the
daily briefings that were coming from
government there were daily briefings
that were coming from
um you know scientists and science-based
organizations
but uh the you know that both in the UK
and further field as well so there would
have been a
um uh you would have had that sort of
daily drum beat of information but also
our journalists were given the the scope
to go and find different angles
different themes encouraged to like to
write longer form pieces as well so that
as as one put it get away from the
um the fog of the story and into the
Nuance so that there are all kinds of
sources for a big Global story like that
and five probably the biggest Global
story that we've seen in our uh in our
lifetimes it's actually putting it down
to where do you go for information is
very difficult because the information
is all around and there are so many
different angles to it yeah like I mean
that's that that's a fair point
um so let me as we move along panel ask
a slightly different question which is
did you discover
quickly who was reliable and who wasn't
no I don't think I don't think we did
um I mean
we we encourage all our correspondence
to to Canvas as many experts in the
field as as possible and I think the
what we discovered was that and it was
by the nature of the fact this was a new
virus that no one had full understanding
or knowledge that at any particular time
there was some organizations that I
think came out better than others in
terms of the information they gave us
I'm thinking about the ons I'm thinking
about the UK HSA
I think the science media center with an
invaluable resource in terms of giving
different voices
at specific times during the
the pandemic but um certainly talking to
our science editor Ian sample and one of
his colleagues Nicola Davis during just
before this session it was very clear to
me that they didn't feel they could
trust any particular Source without at
least trying to triangulate with other
experts
conversation with our health editor
before this Martin Baggett who are the
who's obviously the person in the field
so I I think to Nick's point there was
some concern at the beginning because it
was so unknown although fairly quickly
the daily briefings were incredibly
useful
um and then I think the other the other
major
advantages we had was the science
Medical Center which Nick mentioned
about which I think was always there as
a backstop when people wanted to sort of
sense check anything that they were
hearing from lots of different sources
so they were um they were hugely
important and I think as we kind of all
journalism at the beginning if you've
got a source and you're not entirely
certain
whether it's going to be right or wrong
you you check it and you check it again
and then it becomes clear which are the
ones that you can keep going back to
that are reliable and are closest but
obviously you know as we've seen
subsequently lots of there was lots of
different perspectives and lots of
different and and so it was very much a
case of feeling the way but we feel that
with the daily briefings with the mrha
public health England they were there
there was there was certainly a lot of
information available to us
well I'd give a very similar answer
um I mean we had an awful lot of
journalists not just medical and science
correspondents working on this I think I
worked out at one point
um 80 of our online content was covered
related in one way one way or another
and
information was coming in from all over
the world and I mean some
some aspects of the daily briefings and
government policy
seemed fairly incontrovertible like the
the vaccine program although there were
people out there who were decrying it
others like lockdown and I'm sure we'll
get on to the telegraph Revelations this
week but um clearly the science was
completely unsettled and that was the
sense we had at the time and we looked a
lot at what other countries were doing
and experience of Sweden New Zealand
China people at different ends of the
spectrum and um
tried to work out what was working but
it was evolving I mean nobody knew the
answers to begin with yeah
but you you created your advice two of
the the obvious follow-ups I was going
to do which is sort of the same question
but with with different contexts the
first of which is
um did you ever an in retrospect should
you have
uh allowed anti-vaxx voices any
publicity did did you ever I mean apart
from reporting demos and things like
that
did you allow the opinion that you know
the vaccines were you know Bill Gates
putting chips in us or anything I mean
someone will now produce some story we
wrote but the um it certainly always
seemed to me
um I'm not the editor but the the case
for vaccine was extremely strong
um
um and the lockdown was only a stopgap
measure
um
we I mean there were doubts expressed I
remember about the safety of the
AstraZeneca vaccine which of course we
had to report but the
um
the sort of the uninformed emotional
anti-vaccine message
um I I don't think I gave any any
Credence to I I did slightly Wonder at
the time I mean there was
there was a lot of
noise about anti-vaxxers
and I did slightly Wonder at the time
whether the amount of coverage the
subject was given
was actually counterproductive because
it was encouraging people to think well
that's something in this but but anyway
but no no
uh no is the short answer however we
were very very conscious at the volume
of anti-vaxx uh content that was out
there that was circulating on social
media and particularly in WhatsApp
groups which I think is a real issue
because it goes unseen it particularly
perhaps goes unseen by people within the
mainstream media people like yourselves
perhaps
but this but this but this idea about
how information circulates that can be
unseen by a lot of people in power quite
often and we became very aware of that
and because particularly some of the
people who may have fallen uh under
under the influence of that information
are people who
you know traditionally would have come
to like a mainstream tabloid
organization so we did so we always take
the opinion with something like that we
can't just uh
we can't just tell everybody they're
stupid so we did a lot of myth busting q
and A's trying to explain why uh certain
information was wrong and and trying to
put the facts out there but in a way
that isn't telling everyone that they're
stupid because that's the only way you
can really counteract misinformation
yeah
yeah and guardian has a different market
so yes yeah but I mean we had we took
the same approach which was we wanted to
my recollection in news is that we
wanted to interrogate where
where this was coming from who was who
was
um you know speaking the anti-vaxx
message what were their credentials what
was the background to them try and rap
wrap the issue in that kind of context
um because we couldn't just completely
ignore it but neither did we want to
given
a a platform to a conspiracy theorists
um
yeah I mean you're coming at it from as
it were both ends of the market as well
yeah and look and I think it's also
important to point out that unlike Nick
and Allison I am not currently at the
sharp end of editing
um newspapers which I've done in the
past
um but you know I would agree with
everything that's been said I think as
well
um you know during the pandemic the
government chose to do a lot of
advertising messaging through news
Brands
um because it was found that they gained
uh or the message had a lot more trust
and Credence as a result of being in
that trusted environment
um so there's no doubt that I think
um use plan news Brands played a really
important role during the pandemic of
getting out uh reliable information as
people were crying out for that because
there was so much
um you know misinformation or
um you know the anti-vax message and
then there was a lot of debate also
around
um lockdown which was the other one
which we would certainly have surfaced
the lockdown debate because I think that
was probably more
um
more debatable I can put it like that
but on the whole it was
here is what we think is the consensus
approach here is the myth busting if
you're wondering about it
um this is probably with the best
information we have available to us the
way that we should be moving forward at
this point in time I mean you make the
point about lockdown and clearly this
week's Revelations
make it more relevant I mean I'm struck
in retrospect that
no paper actually sort of started
campaigning against lockdown
as as a tool You know despite all the
arguments about Sweden and other
countries that did it
um sort of in retrospect did that
argument get underplayed by mainstream
papers do you think the anti-lockdown
argument is it is sort of uh so easy to
have an opinion with hindsight and we
were in that we were in the height uh or
in the midst of something that was we'd
never encountered before no one knew
what it was going to do to us
um there was the you know the country
was in a genuine state of fear
um it had
um it there was the real danger the NHS
was going to fall over
those were all the arguments as to why
we should be should be locking down and
I think it was important that the
country got behind that policy and there
was you know the consensus in Parliament
um and I I think consensus in the
general population as things then went
further you could possibly make the
argument that you didn't need the third
or fourth lockdown possibly but it had
got us that far and actually we've come
out the other end of it
um reasonably intact so uh I think it is
uh
we should always be asking questions
but at the same time where there is a a
national need
um I think it is uh you know you get
behind that need
I mean my recollection is there were
some voices Fringe voices
who were anti-lockdown
but you know as David says I mean it's
easy to forget now that
it felt we were in a state of panic a
state of emergency and
um
uh you can look back with hindsight and
think all manner of different things but
at the time
you know our mortality rates were very
high our hospitals were full up you know
that was where the that was that was
that was what we were focused on I think
most people were focused on that
it's only now really now the pandemic is
subsiding that
um the those Fringe voices are have got
more of a platform
yes I I think as Nick says there were
some people that were questioning
lockdown particularly when we went to
the third and fourth I mean I think that
the telegraph perhaps was more
questioning of it but I think also we've
got to remember we serve our audiences
so we serve a print audience and a
digital audience and probably all of our
print audiences are slightly older
they're more conscious about their
health I mean if you take a mirror
audience and you ask them to choose
between a mirror print audience ask them
to use health and wealth they're always
going to go with health so so so all the
economic arguments about lockdown
perhaps were of less value to staying
alive at that point so we are there to
serve our audiences as well so when you
get to a digital audience perhaps
slightly younger sort of more young
people who are adversely affected
economically and also in terms of things
like mental health and they were
actually the physical effects of covid
um that's slightly different as well so
um
but
in hindsight yes possibly there could
have been more questions asked about
lockdown the impacts particularly on
young people but they did start to come
out I think towards the end of the the
end of it all yeah I mean the mail you'd
have thought might be on the the sort of
anti-lockdown
edge of the the argument I I I I I I
think
um we became increasingly skeptical uh
and we were certainly worried
very worried about the effect on
education on children
um and and the effect on the economy and
you know whether it was actually working
and that that's one of the reasons that
we we devoted quite a lot of effort to
look at countries like Sweden that were
handling it differently
um there were also
um I mean this is opinion rather than
reporting but
um certainly my friend Peter Hitchens on
the mail on Sunday was very skeptical
all along
um and so there were always skeptical
voices
um
um but I I do agree with my colleagues
that
whatever we've now learned
it's hard to see what the government
could have done at the beginning other
given how little we knew about all this
and the fact there was no vaccine
available yeah and is that what it felt
like at the time because obviously this
is an inquiry into trusted voices and
David made the point that and and after
you you've each got you know clearly a
different market and and you want your
readers to trust you and and
particularly uh in the context of an
online world where all kinds of
craziness is going on and a lot of
people are believing it did you see the
role as very much a saying hang on
don't don't believe these mad voices
we've actually done some proper
journalism on this so even in in a
climate of deep uncertainty about what
would happen next because the whole
world didn't know anything about this
pandemic that that you had that role to
play I I I I I think we did on vaccine
um and
we were very skeptical about some of the
miracle cures that were being toted
um yes
um
although even there there were
occasionally sort of contradictory
stories from possibly reputable sources
there to be looked into but
um
we were I'd well I repeat I'd
I can't really see what else the
government could have done
I mean I don't think the government
could have stood there and said the
answer to this is herd immunity which in
the end it is
um and therefore a lot of a lot of
British citizens are going to lose their
lives because we won't achieve it
straight away I mean you couldn't have
you couldn't have done that
um we were certainly
um
skeptical and critical of the way
lockdown applied to Care Homes
there was a lot of concern about that
yeah
thanks yeah I want to continue on some
of these themes you know from different
sort of titles different Traditions
different politics
I just wondered
in this day and age you're competing
with different stuff I imagine the
circulations are declining from the
Heyday of Fleet Street
to sort of reliably buy a newspaper and
Peter Wright interestingly the Metro is
that the one with the biggest
circulation because you just kind of
pick it up without trying on the tube
every morning
the saturation figures who reads it
compared to the male compared to the
online version for all of you yeah
um I'm a Metro was hit very badly by by
lockdown as you can imagine
um very badly indeed
um and prior to lockdown it was the
biggest by circulation
um
Metro
a Metro appeals to young people
um because it's a commuter newspaper and
[Music]
it's it's policy is to be incredibly
straightforward in its reporting of news
I mean it it will give you short stories
without spin
um
and
try to sort of Keep Us close to Common
Ground as it possibly can
um
the male by contrast the newspaper
rather than online
has an older readership it's a
campaigning paper it has a political
view and it's not afraid of expressing
it
um mail online has a much younger
audience
um is it still the most read website in
the world for a while it was awesome uh
it it was the most read newspaper
website right
um
um BBC is bigger
but yeah I mean it it um I was just
checking the latest figures for a 180
million unique visitors every month
um what's that compared to the newspaper
newspaper I think currently sells
um
somewhere between six and seven hundred
thousand copies
so readership you can multiply that by
two
and on Sunday a bit more because of the
color magazine uh no slightly less oh
really okay and Metro what's that is not
the biggest thing I I'm afraid I'd okay
I haven't got a figure but but it's
it's in in a similar region
um
and that's six to seven hundred thousand
this down on what it was a couple of
decades ago I'm imagining when I when I
left to Mel on Sunday in 2012 we were
selling two million
um and the Daily Mail was selling
something similar and in its Heyday we
were selling some some Sundays we sold
over two and a half million
um so
um and I'm sure everybody along here
will be doing exactly the same story
um you know I'm afraid
um
I'm afraid
newspapers will not be with us forever
and
um the the problem is that the uh the
advertising has gone online
um the all the marginal costs have
increased newsprint is more expensive
because we're buying it in smaller
quantities the
um the Paper Industries in serious
problems and
if you're if you're not taking
advertising Revenue you have to put your
cover price up
and cover prices become a larger and
larger percentage of our revenue and of
course when you put the cover price up
it is sales it's inevitable and I I
doubt if anybody's got a different story
to tell we're afraid yeah Allison yeah
um so I mean print circulation
um has gone down
um but I don't think
but but digital the mirror is actually
reaching more people in many ways than
it ever has done so you know we'll get
10 million hits a day on our website so
there's the opportunity we're reaching a
younger audience so but but we kind of
almost like playing those those two two
audiences I like to think sort of our
digital audience and our print audience
there they it was like a sort of a
father and son they sort of share the
same values and the same beliefs but
they might wear different clothes so
it's but it's that's the kind of the the
how we operate in print
um as Peter says cover price increases
which we've seen many of
um unfortunately we are losing readers
but there is a huge loyalty amongst
those people that do stay so we in many
regards we almost regard the mirror as a
kind of a club that just so happens to
bring out a daily news product because
there is a real sort of sense of
belonging and that was hugely powerful
in the early days of covid because for
people that weren't even leaving their
homes they were still at the sale really
held up during so if people were going
out for one thing you have to go and buy
a paper because that was kind of their
connection to the world and also it was
something that allowed people to fill
their days it was something to do and we
felt our role in people's lives grew
enormously during that period and the
relationship we had with our print
readers grew enormously during that
period even though it had always been
strong
so there's that and then but obviously
so much of the work that we're trying to
do as I'm sure our colleagues are is to
replicate that kind of depth of
relationship with our digital readers
but of course the way people access
digital news is quite different largely
people Reach digital news through their
Facebook feed or through their social
media platforms whoever they use so
that's much more of a pick and mix so
somebody picks up their phone in the
morning they go to Facebook and they
might see one story from the mail next
door from the mirror next door from the
guardian and so it's it's a very
different relationship and it's much
harder to build those uh that loyalty
the dream is that people wake up in the
morning and they go to a destination
website which I mean the guardian's gone
a long way in that in that regard
obviously the BBC is cleaned up because
it's free and then but that's how we're
all trying to kind of get at those
relationships digitally so younger
people just not in the habit of picking
up a newspaper anymore oh no no no I
mean that's but that's fine as long as
people are accessing their news
somewhere
um but the the harder bit isn't as much
that they're not picking up a newspaper
it's more that they've grown up not
recognizing the need to pay for news so
that's where it gets really difficult
well it's digital really yes yeah and
what's the circulation out of Interest
so we're around about 3 30 now okay and
the guardian I can't give you the
circulation figures because as head of
news it's not something that aren't
necessarily
um uh I I keep details of I can
certainly get them to you I am too I
imagine it's pretty big because we're
not behind a paywall or anything well
our readership online is huge and
um you know regularly we're between sort
of 40 and 15 million readers
uh uh or page views being read a day
during covid it was much higher than
that still in fact we saw a massive
spike in traffic throughout the um
throughout the pandemic
um and and like everyone else I mean I
know that there's been a gradual decline
in our paper readership through that
time but
you know we do have loyal we do have
loyal Guardian paper readers and we
don't necessarily think that they're the
same readers as the ones we have online
well I would say this I think the
guardian is a sort of terrific mix of
very very trusted news and I think our
news throughout the pandemic was very
highly regarded and very well trusted
from the research that has been done on
this
um and it's always been a good mix of
um you know news investigations
highly opinionated pieces in the uh in
our opinion section so people still like
it
since well how do you
survived between the quality the
tabloids and what do people look for in
a newspaper who stuck with it
um so I I want to tell a positive story
about this and and I think uh you
shouldn't think in terms of print and
digital I think you should think in
terms of total audience you are behind a
paywall aren't you on the times yeah and
we have an organization called palmco
which I think stands for the Publishers
audience measurement company and they do
an independent uh survey a couple of
times a year which gives total audiences
of newspapers
dupes print and digital so you get to
you get to the right figure and that has
the sun is the biggest in the country at
around 30 million mirror just behind
that Mill just behind that in terms of
total audience
um this is hey it's on the internet yeah
both print and digital so looking at the
total audience the number of people who
consume the brand
at a point in the month uh and as I say
that's where you get to that that total
audience number so that's a huge reach
and if you compare that I mean I was
looking at some figures earlier and
and in the 15 to 34 age group which
would be predominantly digital
um we as news brands are reaching 14
million across print and online every
month which is six million more than
Snapchat and 5 million more than Tick
Tock now you'd be forgiven for thinking
everybody was on uh Tick Tock and
Snapchat but actually they're consuming
errors in greater numbers which is a
really good story going forward and then
the the other thing is the the evolution
of news and how it has changed uh in in
recent years so if you take the times
for example
um still got a strong print
sale that will go from about 300 000
during the week up to 500 000 at the
weekends
um Sunday Times Sunday Times about that
Saturday times Saturday Saturday is the
biggest selling day of the week except
on the times where the Sunday Times out
strips it but the male's biggest sale is
on a Saturday it does over a million
some does over a million on a Saturday
as well so Saturday is now that is the
new Sunday in that respect
um but times has evolved from being a
print product alone to website apps and
now radio station as well to increase
its reach so we launched times radio at
the uh at the the height of the pandemic
actually
um which has opened us up to a whole new
audience but also given our journalists
another way of reaching uh reaching
their existing audience as well so you
know what were traditionally newspapers
are now that's why we refer to them as
news Brands different ways of
communicating and that is what the
audiences require how do you keep your
readers of the print version page three
is gone I think history has gone 2015.
um so well again there's no doubt that
the print sales are declining but there
is still a really loyal base there
predominantly in the sort of over 50
over 60 category and actually when you
get into the over 70 category uh the
usage of the internet among our
readerships and I think the mirror will
be is in fact I know the mirror is
similar in this it is really low so in
that sort of c c to d e demographic
is not a daily habit so it won't have
smartphones and will rely on print to
get their information so it's really
important that we keep print alive for
that demographic for you know the the
next couple of decades so these elements
of what people look for in the newspaper
how did they inform you your covid
coverage
say compared to the brexit coverage I
mean were you sort of trying to reflect
back what your readers think or did you
see it as a more of a informing what the
government line was yeah I'm looking out
to these I think the big stories we've
already covered I think the the
predominant
um
uh feeling among the readership and
among the country was one of fear as we
went into this what does this mean what
does it mean from for me what does it
mean for my family how do I protect me
how do I protect my family those were
the sort of these were
um pretty base questions that we were we
were trying to answer and I think that
was uh I mean I I personally think news
Brands played a Blinder during this
period uh as as Peter said you know
every basically every journalist was
working on this story and trying to
produce as much
um trusted and trustworthy information
as as possible ask questions when there
were questions there to be asked but
also getting across the key messages
when they did have to be got across and
you know the sun
um uh launched their Jabs Army campaign
on the 1st of January 2021 which was how
can we get volunteers to to help out at
vaccination centers and within 18 days I
think they'd signed up sixty thousand
people which showed the the convening
power of the Sun but also the trust that
people had in the Sun that they wanted
to get involved they wanted to help out
so I think all those things help to to
build The Narrative of how we approached
it in brexit is it the case that the son
of Scotland whatever it's called sun in
Scotland was Scottish yeah does it
remain a title compared to the one the
rest of them and we you know according
to your region our editors have uh have
the you know the freedom to to talk to
the audiences that they set up I I
edited both the Scottish son and the sun
in in London
um so and and we did approach things in
in different ways because they are
they're different countries with uh
different you know parliaments in many
ways different organizations different
cultures
I do have some figures for you
um
um I didn't want you to be I give you a
misleading ones so the circulation of
the garden is around a hundred thousand
um and according to the pamco print and
online metric that David's just
mentioned we're at 24.6 million unique
users
um so uh and in terms of going towards
the pay model is it because it kind of
or not so they know who you are no I
don't think we I think it sort of says
register here we we look for subscribers
um but we're very much not behind a
paywall and that's not the way uh we
have gone
um in terms of
our coverage during the pandemic I think
the the key thing was just explain
explain
the best performing pieces or some of
them
um were always the ones where we were
doing we were posing questions to
ourselves and then getting someone you
know one of our Specialists science
editorial Health Editor to answer them
there was just an absolute first for a
the kind of what's happening right now
so the devices of the live blogging that
we have which we've established over a
number of years we're incredibly useful
in that regard but then they're slightly
more reflective
pieces
how do we
how do we make sense of what we've just
been told the step back explainers FAQs
things like that there was a a real
first podcast yeah we do those too and
that's another really good device for
being able to sometimes the news story
can seem quite brutal you know it's uh
by its necessity you know it'll have a
sharp top and there was a kind of
formula to a new story something like an
explainer or a conversation that's had
in something like today and focus allows
you to be a bit more conversational
brexit not
explaining but people know there's lots
of explaining in in brexit and lots of
kind of context as well
because
you know
um
in both in both stories people were
saying things that needed to be
interrogated and you didn't want to
leave
um
you didn't want to leave the news story
on its own you wanted to build to step
back reflect on what was being said are
we being or being told the truth of
being misled
thanks
oh sorry I'm sorry
anything else from any of these two
no yeah I mean I mean all I I would say
that I mean they're very very different
types of of stories and kovid was all
about a thirst for information
um and it which which is is great in a
way for for journalists because it's
it's basic journalism it's it's
reporting fact
um or trying to discern fact from
fiction
um I mean we we also I mean we've run a
massive campaign to um
acquire uh
um equipment for the NHS
um which
um readers engage with on a massive
scale
um so it was a very good sort of um
an exercise in both informing readers
and empowering them
thank you chair and thanks for coming to
give evidence to us today
um so the um the science Media Center
describes science and health reporters
as allies in the fight against
misinformation
so did you feel the duty to combat
misinformation in the way that you
reported during the pandemic
and how did you balance that between the
need to get out public messages that
were coming from the government but also
to be questioning of those public
messages and you know providing scrutiny
um you know so
just of three questions in one there to
move us on a bit but if I start with you
uh David and then we'll do the same go
across
um
so I mean I think we've touched on quite
a lot of this already in terms of the uh
you know the the messages that were
coming out from science organizations I
think like if if it's coming from a
credible science organization that
that's that gives them a good start but
it's not a free pass to this information
is 100 uh 100 correct
uh and I think it is the job of
journalists and news organizations to
you know to to challenge around the
fringes on this I mean let's face it if
we uh if we based our financial future
and the consensus of economists it
probably wouldn't be the uh the the best
way the best way forward
um and and I think that uh
I was I was struck I was listening to uh
times radio this morning and there was
uh uh Tom Whipple our our health editor
science editor sorry who who played a
big role in in the pandemic coverage uh
was on there and he was talking about
um editing genomes of God's bacteria and
I thought it was a it was a classic case
of science reporting
um he's using phrases like there is a
growing body of evidence it is linked to
they are claims that the thing about
science is we don't actually know
exactly what is happening and and how it
is going to turn out so I think uh when
we are reporting these things we are
giving them Credence but there is always
a big question mark uh at the end of the
sentence if that uh if that if that
makes sense to you I think that's an
important thing to understand and the
role that the journalist plays in it but
did
did the need to um you know to to
provide a balanced uh
um range of information but put it that
way uh during the pandemic where people
needed to understand what was going on
where there was clearly a need for
public messaging to uh to to to
advise about lockdowns and uh accepting
the vaccine Etc did that state your hand
at all in being being the the usual in
the usual scrutiny that you would
provide of a of a government um no I as
I say I think there was some there was
so much work being done on so many
different aspects of this story that
having literally a stone wasn't Unturned
um I so no I don't I don't think it did
I certainly wasn't aware of you know the
stories being pulled or that sort of
thing that's that's just not the case
and I think that as
um you know as the as recent months have
come to pass
you know there's not really much that's
a marriage that wasn't being you know
that has shown that we we took the wrong
decisions at the time the thing is you
can you can do both can't you you can
report the news and then interrogate the
news and and that's what we try to do
and I don't think at any point during
the pandemic did we ever
decide we weren't going to run a story
you know we stuck the boot into Matt
Hancock repeatedly we we highlighted
what we regarded
as
um as concerns over VIP lanes and
tomocracy and you know the scandals
within the procurement of PPE so you
know I I've felt that we could do we
could do both and certainly our science
correspondents are among the most
inquisitive and in some ways I'm
trusting of all our correspondence they
they'll listen to One expert and then
immediately get on the phone and want to
talk to another one to challenge their
opinion so I felt we were in good hands
um and I didn't feel that the need to
report the news at any point prevent
this from interrogating it or from
highlighting scandals where we thought
they existed
of Boris Johnson's government at that
point in many ways and you know as Nick
says we we looked at them in the
um the way Care Homes were treated at
that point we did a huge amount of
Stories on that PPE
um there were there were a lot of issues
that we were very very strong on at that
stage
um but in terms of the science and in
terms of the health messaging
um
we we and in the briefings we trusted we
trusted Chris Whitey we trusted Patrick
Valance we trusted Johnson van Tam and
then because it wasn't just the daily
briefings that that we were getting that
people were seeing on the television we
were also getting uh off the Record
briefings from those people as well to
our reporters
so there was a background and an
understanding of what was going on
um and then we absolutely interrogated
that evidence because I sort of think my
role as an editor is to ask all the
questions that people sitting at home
are asking when they've watched
something on the television at that
night so so well why are they saying
that how come last week um the chief
nurse was saying that we were going for
herd immunity and now we've all dropped
the idea of her immunity and we put
those questions in day after day and we
try to put in using a range of experts
and using all the information we're
getting as well from sources such as
science Media Center to to try to really
explain
and reassure our readers as well that
because people want to understand
because if they don't fully understand a
problem then they're never going to feel
any sense of security and at that point
a lot of our role was to try to create
that sense of security
so you absolutely can do as Nick said
you can provide that information which
gives people sense of security but you
can also question a lot of the political
decisions that will be made at that
point yeah I've just done a bit about
the private briefings that you had with
uh the the scientists that were you know
we were seeing on on the news every day
looking back now do you do you feel that
they were full and Frank or that they
were trying to manage the information at
times
there has been some interesting things
that have come out in the WhatsApp
messages haven't they in the last time
fortnight
um which perhaps did made me question
last week if there were occasions when
some of those scientists
should have publicly said that they were
unhappy but I guess they too were in
this situation whereby
they felt that unity and putting on that
front to the public was was the best
um was the best idea
um
certainly in terms of the
scientific and health advice we were
getting from them at the time I think
they were
giving that to the best of their ability
whether they had to compromise in some
areas that were more around policy on
things like lockdown I guess that's for
them
I mean I I think
um
we
we were were skeptical
about various aspects uh of of the story
of this easiest way of encapsulating it
um and um
and and this sort of happened as it went
along because when it started
we didn't know any more than anybody
else about all this we you know we we
weren't in a position where we could
possibly have said lockdown was the
wrong policy uh when it was introduced
because we simply didn't have a body of
knowledge about it
um but the the worth there were things
that
um that were being done which
one then started to be skeptical about
and I I remember in the very early days
the um
the the medical establishment uh
invested an awful lot of Hope in
ventilators and they were you know and
we did stories about entrepreneurs who
were going to produce massive numbers of
ventilators and you know if we could
find a way of building enough
ventilators quickly and cheaply enough
this was going to be the solution and we
then began to hear
that actually
ventilators possibly were not saving
people's lives and we sent a reporter to
New York where we interviewed a young
doctor working in a
um
an intensive care ward in a new hospital
and he explained to us why he thought
they they weren't the solution and I as
far as I'm aware ventilators are very
rarely used in covert cases now so you
you sort of
to begin with you
you you begin because this is all new
accepting what the medical establishment
is accepting and then as time goes along
you you start finding
um dissenting voices and and you go and
talk to them and there were
um
I mean we
the other question that we put effort
into was was the origins of kovid now we
still don't know for certain
but
um
the the possibility that it was a leak
from
um
The Institute of virology in Wuhan was
denounced as a conspiracy theory for a
long time to the point where Facebook
and Twitter
actually banned posts on the subject
when Joe Biden became president he he
instructed the U.S government to look at
it again and last week the FBI said they
think that is now the likely origin we
still don't know but
um you do
I mean I think sometimes you have to ask
questions that people don't want you to
ask
um and there were certainly people in
the medical establish who didn't want to
consider
um
questions like that about how the how
the virus began
we're here to discussing trusted voices
and I think people would question us if
there was no mention of uh WhatsApp gate
at all at this committee this morning
so with all your experience
have you ever
experienced a time when a politician has
become such a trusted source of
information as Nick Hancock has over the
last week
foreign
it is a fascinating
Treasure Trove of information on uh on
that period in history isn't it and uh
and I think one of the dangers that we
actually face now weirdly with all the
electronic communications you speak to
historians no and they're worried about
how we will be able to develop history
in the future
because there's not anything written
down and things can get destroyed so I
think it is important that we do think
about how these things are captured for
the future does it shed any light on The
Trusted voices that we were listening to
during the covert period do you think
that makes us rethink how we should
approach that in the future
yeah but I mean I do also think getting
back to the the point around uh the
chaos of the situation if you are trying
to run something be it a business or a
country or whatever you should be asking
yourselves questions internally as well
and then some sometimes when those
questions I'm not saying that uh this
doesn't excuse everything that's in the
in the WhatsApp Treasure Trove but
sometimes when those questions do come
out in the cold light day with hindsight
that they don't look particularly clever
but they're probably the right questions
to be asking at the time to get to the
right decision
anybody have so many observations on on
WhatsApp gate this week
in a lot of what we've been discussing I
mean I've not seen anything in in that
that makes me question
what the
um the chief medical officer or or those
people were instructing I mean they may
have had
they made them in terms of they may have
compromised on some issues that they
thought or perhaps for the national good
but I don't think in terms of the actual
information they were giving there was I
haven't seen anything that makes me
doubt that I mean obviously there's
quite a lot that makes you doubt some of
the political judgments were being made
but
but I don't think
I don't well I mean certainly from our
perspective I don't think
the politicians were the trusted voices
in the whole thing it was it was the the
medical people the health people they
were the trusted voices
last week pretty depressing honestly
um
I
I mean I I I think
people generally thought with each
lockdown that they were doing it for for
absolutely
um
um 100 medical reasons
and
we now know that the the Medical Science
was best uncertain particularly as time
went on
um and that it was being done for
political reasons because
um the government wanted to show it's
doing something
um
so I think you know if we're talking
about
trust
um
it it's worrying and I I don't know
about others but in another situation
a similar situation in the future maybe
avian bird flu
and the government starts
um wanting to impose
patterns of behavior on people which are
going to disrupt their lives people are
going to be more questioning inevitably
the you know there can't be another
another consequence of what we've
learned over the last week I don't think
the
um I mean one of the
one of the surprises is
um I mean this sort of government by
WhatsApp I think even has taken us by
surprise it's so much
so many conversations were being had and
frankly there is as Petty
and the language is
so petty in it in this in the
conversations I think is a real that's
one surprise I mean the other thing I
would say though is that
um you know it's a great it's a great
Scoop from the telegraph
but what I don't think it does is
provide any context and this is this is
something we've tried to do at the
guardian which is at each of the points
where there were these discussions going
on there's not
as far as I can see that much reflection
on what the country was going through at
that particular time the number of
people who were in hospital the stretch
there was on the NHS the number of
people who were dying the sort of
there's that's that's where I sort of
feel that we have a job to do to try and
explain a little bit more and remind
people about what was going on at the
time yeah pressures in schools as well
and and also I suppose it's difficult
we've got to have within this
conversation as well amongst those you
know the politicians and the supposed
trusted voices we also now know that
there was a huge amount of rule breaking
going on
um and that
um and that does lie at the heart of it
really in that that's going to cause a
breakdown of trust between the public
and the supposed trusted voices and
with the guardian we ran the exclusive
with the Dominic Cummings and Barnard
castle and all that story which was back
in the um May of 2020
um and I remember feeling thinking
really long and hard when we ran that
story because I felt a huge level of
responsibility what if this running this
story
um destroys trust to such an extent that
we the public health message completely
breaks down and then
people stop abiding by the lockdown
rules and I thought a personal way of
responsibility at that point but we also
obviously felt that the overwhelming
need that that was in the public
interest that needed to be out there but
I think sometimes journalists were more
concerned about the importance of trust
than perhaps some of the people who were
making the policy
thank you
chair good morning
um
one of the things that's that I've now
notice about journalism is that it's one
of the five least trusted professions in
the country now I dare add that I think
politicians are trusted less
um so it's important to caveat that as
as you're sitting in front of a bunch of
politicians um what accounts do you
think for low levels of trust
in journalists David if I can come to
you first
um I like the way that I start them all
right it's just because I know I always
go with that
um
so I look I I think we are uh you know
we are big organizations we're big
public organizations in the way that as
well MPS are are part of a big public
organization as well and therefore
people it is easy for people to have an
opinion of it
um I think the statistics uh around
trust in news brands are slightly
different and when people are surveyed
uh they are they actually
um put whether it's print or online they
put a lot of trust in in what they
actually read so I think there's a
difference between the do you trust
journalists and do you trust the what
the what their actual output is and I
think that's an important uh that does
that does bear fruit in the Reuters
Institute for the study of Journalism
they did a report and brand trust scores
were heavily variable depending on the
brand and depending on the publisher all
that kind of stuff
um Nick the same question to you what
why do you think that some people have a
low level of trust with journalists
well
um I mean there have been scandals over
the years that have painted journalists
not in terrifically positive like the
phone hacking scandals obviously the the
main one
um
but you know as David says actually I
think there is a difference between
journalists and journalistic Brands and
I think I'm not saying the guardian
doesn't have a problem we'll we have to
be mindful of
of misinformation and we do our very
best to ensure that we don't publish
wrong stories and incorrect stories but
from what I can see of the studies that
have done for instance on our coverage
of covid and our coverage of the
environment we're a very highly trusted
news brand and we really value and
cherish that
Allison
um I think it might be slightly more
news than just different brands have
different levels of trust I think it's
the relationship between a reader and
that brand
so somebody says um I may not trust
journalists but then then if they're a
mirror reader oh I really trust the
mirror I've been reading the mirror 20
years I know all the writers I know the
columnists because you've got a
relationship and I'm sure it's exactly
the same for the sun people who buy the
sun will trust the Sun but they not may
not necessarily trust uh other brands or
journalists generally for example I
imagine lots of people say oh no I don't
trust politicians okay do you trust your
own constituent constituency uh MP oh
yeah he's really nice bloke it's that so
if you've got a relationship with
somebody it's different to sort of
journalists in the broad brush stroke
um so so I think it's that and I think
it's
um I think there is data as well that
shows that our trust scores as an
industry did go up following covert as
well because I think we were so out
there not just telling these we're
explaining the news and maybe we just
need to do more of that Peter
yeah
um I mean I I'm familiar with the
Reuters research there's also some
recently published of com research which
shows
um that print newspapers are very close
in trust to TV and at a high level 71
for TVs 67 for print
um social media 35 percent
now I I was at a
um
ofcom conference last week where the
Reuters Institute
um produced some fascinating survey
research on young people's consumption
of news
um 18 to 25 year olds
um and they told us that of the people
they surveyed
um
only 25 had actually accessed
uh news from a traditional provider
whether TV or newspaper in the last
month 75 hadn't at all
and when they asked they were asked
where they got their news from
they said social media when they were
asked what does that mean Tick Tock
Snapchat and Facebook and what they were
actually consuming and calling news
was
um posts by influencers and celebrities
um isn't this gay I mean yes
as a former journalist I didn't say at
the the the top of this because it was a
broadcast channel as opposed to a print
journalist working for the BBC and ITV
doesn't it scare you that that's that is
a growing Trend and I think you we all
saw it during the pandemic we saw the
the Avalanche of new community groups on
social media sites as well so moving
away from Tick Tock I don't know I
didn't I didn't go on Tick Tock I think
it's utterly baffling I'm only 37 but
the um but don't you think this is this
is a really worrying Trend because trust
in journalism proper rigorous journalism
is is really important because people
get their news and it's fair and it can
be balanced and everything else like
that obviously arguments are bias either
way on all different kinds of
Publications but if young people are
accessing news in that way
and not going to even you know the sort
of news that's developed especially
specifically for them Radio One newsbeat
whatever it might be
are you facing extinction
no it's our responsibility to go to
where the audience are I mean audiences
have always evolved and changed
um and there are news organizations that
are going to survive have got to evolve
and we've got to that's why you know
probably all the people around the table
are investing in in Snapchat and Tick
Tock we've got to
it we've got to go to where the audience
is and we've got to ensure that we are
creating trusted news that they want to
access it's so difficult having been as
Leep trendy
and other websites as well now these are
Snippets of like clips and news you
can't really contextualize a proper
story in that can you so are we
cheapening news Well by using these
platforms no because I think it's it's
different because because people change
they grow up they through their life
they want different things from their
news as well so it's not a one solution
fits all I'm sure to be honest you could
have sat here 30 years ago and bemoan
young people or they're not interested
in the world around them that's always
been but people I'm not saying that by
the way I'm still relatively young
myself but I think but I think things
adapt and it's as people become more
invested in society their children go to
school they use public services that
they become more aware of the society
around them and therefore they've got
more investment in understanding the
world around them and trying to make
sense of it so I think it's the onus is
on us to tailor our news to the
different audiences I hope you're right
Alice and I hope you're right it's not
without a challenge no it is but it's
um but we have to keep fighting
absolutely really
um if I can I'd like to draw a
comparison between professional
newspapers and local newspapers now we
know that local journalism has really
struggled in recent years local
newspapers have closed the Staffing
levels within local newspapers has
diminished somewhat there is work being
done through the local democracy
reporting service to try and strengthen
local reporting of of council staff that
goes on and I've sat in Council meetings
and you know uh some of which most of
which weren't particularly enjoyable but
there were there were news Snippets out
of it but they are trusted local
journalists local papers are trusted
more than National Brands is that
because there's a perception that
journalists could live in their street
David
yeah I mean I I again I think it's back
to that point of who you know who you've
got the connection with who you've got
the who is in your community so I think
it probably is from that the difficulty
now is with the
um the challenges the local newspapers
are facing is that they may well not
have somebody in that Community uh and
and I think they are the Canary in the
coal mine for news in general and that
more and more so local community news is
provided by untrained
um uh sources that you don't know
whether anything's been checked out if I
may can I use an example so yeah there
was a there was an online news site in
my county of Devon a couple of years ago
which just allowed
the councils and the police to upload
press releases they'll then be turned
into news stories
I mean that's pretty bad isn't it yes
that's not journalists it is absolutely
not right it's a it's a
um
it's a wall in which you stick your
poster basically
um it's absolutely not journalism so I
as I say Canary in the coal mine it is
something we need to sort out we need to
find new models for this I mean just if
I could go back on the
um the the other point of what happens
to National newspapers and news in
general the important thing to remember
is that there's only one group creating
the raw material and that is
professional news providers trusted raw
material everything else is feeding off
that
um and when you get into these platforms
actually a Snapchat I think is not a
good example because they do have brand
specific channels that you go into
um but on Tick Tock and so on which is
just a flick through the brand blindness
that you get there you've no idea where
it's coming from people will say they
get their news from Facebook but
actually they're clicking or they're
seeing it from the sound
whatever and then you take the next
evolution of this which is into
artificial intelligence and chat GPT
if we start off with you know a Google
search term which provides you a load of
answers where you can see what the
source is
and then you move to the Other Extreme
which is chat GPT where you put in your
question and you're provided with an
answer where you've no idea where it's
come from no idea whether it's true but
you can guarantee that it is scraped our
content somewhere along the way to come
up with that answer could it also be and
I'll come to Nick for this particular
point if I may that with local
journalism there can be less of a group
think mentality we know that Investments
do you have the lobby and they have
briefings and all that kind of stuff
it's quite closed shop do you think that
that can be detrimental as well as
beneficial to those Publishers who are
part of it
but I think it comes back to the
different relationship there is between
I mean I started I started on a weekly
newspaper and then an evening newspaper
and I will remember the the relationship
between the readers and us as reporters
was very different to the National
scenario it was quite intimate they
turned up in our you know uh in our you
know in our offices and they you know
they had access to us at Council
meetings they it was a much more
personal and intimate relationship than
there is probably with with uh with
national with national readers of course
local press has been a withering for all
the reasons we know and that's a real
it's a real it's a it's a real problem
for us and it's a real problem to the
sort of the Ecology of news
um not least because we don't tend to
it's very difficult for for journalists
now to get into
uh to get International newspapers
there's not the the route that I went
to weekly newspapers and evening
newspaper that's that's a much more
perilous route now than it ever used to
be salaries are low people can't afford
to continue to do it they're going
working funnily enough PR
for a short period but going back to my
point particularly about Regional versus
National
is is group think can can that be a
problem
um I think group thing is a problem at
the guardian
maybe not the god Alison or the male
no I I I don't really think that's one
of the big issues that we face at all
um I mean certainly within the lobby
there's all sorts of different
um
and within every Newsroom really
um I guess my point is wouldn't it be
great if that was opened up to a more
Regional
strategy so you had more people from the
regions that could come and be part of
those briefings and and everything else
we did we did
um
titles do obviously have people here
um but I think as we've we've discussed
it's it's a real challenge in in the
regional press at the moment
um
but the plurality sorry the plurality of
our national news Brands is something to
be cherished for exactly that reason
that we don't have group thing there are
you know the wonderful thing I think
about newspapers in the UK is that there
are biases and that you do know where
it's coming from and that's what avoids
that group think I can't say it's quite
the same as Sports reporters slightly
different
I mean a couple of observations
um I mean and I worked in local papers
as well and
um
with a local paper
you you have a direct connection with
the news you know it was a big plume of
smoke
um over on the other side of town last
night and the next day you read the
paper and there's the explanation and
then you go to work and you can see the
burnt out building so you know it's
happened
um if you choose to be untrusting you
see the same report in a national paper
you've got no way of checking it
yourself but I I am deeply worried about
the
um lack of on the ground reporting by
local papers these days and
uh for my sins for some years I sat on
the complaints commission committee at
ipso and a growing category of
complaints is
um people complaining about court cases
that have been reported in the local
paper and you discover they've been
reported from a police press release
now the police are not a neutral party
in the court case in a criminal court
case
um where it's the local paper reporter
is
um
and
um I I think that's deeply worrying the
other thing that's happened to a lot of
local papers is they've vastly increased
the amount of centrally produced content
because it's it's cheaper so you know
local
it's it's deeply concerning that local
paper reporting is is at such a low end
check thank you before I move to Kevin
can I just thank Allison for using
exactly the same point about how readers
trust their own newspapers more than
they trust newspapers generally as all
politicians news that that
MPS are more trusted by their own
constituents than by others this is a
rare moment of Harmony between
politicians Kevin
thank you chair it's funny Allison you
talk about the the brands or the daily
mirrors as a club because I remember
being a member of The Daily Mirror pop
Club when I was a teenager which helped
me to acquire tickets to see Bob Marley
and the Whalers in Cardiff so a very
fond memories of being a member of The
Daily Mirror pop Club but I wondered
what what's the process we're talking
about trust and so on what's the process
by which you you've seek to verify a
story
um you know when when something comes up
so I asked you first Allison since we're
uh yes so
um I mean a reporter I mean I don't know
how much detail you want on this but so
if a report we'll come here they'll talk
to their news editor
um probably the news as the deception
users who will be involved in the
conversation if it's a big story
um they will discuss what the story is
okay have you managed to get a second
Source on that have you managed to get a
third Source on that because depending
on the the
scale of the story and the possible
ramifications we'll want two or three
sources
um then that will go to the uh lawyer
there'll then be a conversation with the
lawyer or the copy will go to the lawyer
if it's written
um who will sort of go through any
possible uh legal issues then it will
get listed in conference at which point
I'll ask about a million really annoying
questions which just drives the news up
the wall so we just check that we're all
bottomed out on the facts they would
then be discussed later on in the day
um if it's appearing in the print
edition it would then go through
um the back bench so the night editor it
then goes through the middle bench which
is the chief Subs it then goes to the
Saab it then goes back to the middle
bench it then goes through the lawyer
again and then it will appear in print
so it's a pretty robust system and would
it be fair to say that's the same system
that pretty much everybody would follow
in your you know organizations is there
any if there's not a dissenting voice
from that or a different process then
Center voice is a really interesting
point as well so when it's discussed in
conference which is a really great
opportunity similar to this lot of
people sat around the table and if
somebody says more I don't know that
doesn't sound right to me so there's
lots of opportunities for the problems
to be flushed out do you ever go ahead
with the story field when you've got a
single source and would there be
circumstances that might happen
uh in that scenario what you will do is
you'll put
out which is also when you've got the
story you then go to the person who's
impacted by the story and say right
these are the allegations what is your
response
um so if you can't if they come back
with a flat denial that's not true then
we go back to the drawing board if it's
um you know they'd make some quote or
statement which so they're not
absolutely denying it you've given them
the opportunity tonight but they're
trying to sort of Flim Flam around it
then we would run it in that scenario
why don't they ignore you
if they ignore us it's much more
difficult and then
it depends I mean if we would probably
go back several times and if we think
they're deliberately ignoring us then
that's
I want to go back to this business of
the the whatsapps and the uh the the
stories this week and so on because
um
I take it David from what you said um
that you know it was a great scoop for
the telegraph that had Isabella shot
brought you this story that that your
titles would have been likely to publish
that is that a fair assumption
thing you need to you need to ask the
editors
let's just ask you in a different way
then I mean as a someone who's been a an
editor yourself and as a you know a
journalist and so on would you if you'd
been approached and you were in charge
of a a national title
um take on that kind of story it's very
difficult not to give great
consideration to a story of such Merit I
think with Facebook to come to the
guardian
might sign the far-fetched idea but and
with with yes with with the historians
[Laughter]
what would your reaction have been well
um I think uh we would have considered
it we'd have looked at the the material
on its merits I think we would have
probably if we were going to publish it
we'd have probably done it in a in a
slightly different way what would be
different about the way the guardian
would have done it well
um I think that
the I think that putting Isabel Workshop
so front and center of it
um
is problematic was problematic
because it would have been for us anyway
because
um Isabel has a view
about lockdown
um as does the telegraph
and we would be very careful I think to
intermingle with a news story commentary
in the way that the telegraph has and we
know why the telegraph has done it in
this way
um it's just we would have done it I'm
not criticizing the telegraph the way
they've done I'm just saying we'd have
done it differently okay Allison with
the mayor of public yes I mean
the Telegraph and this Workshop do have
a anti-lockdown agenda we didn't we were
aired on the side of caution in terms of
the lockdowns however I do think those
WhatsApp messages are in the public
interest and we would have used them
okay and and Peter do you have a view
yes I I agree with Alice and I think
they were very much in the public
interest
um we don't really know the exact nature
of this non-disclosure agreement which
you would have wanted to see
um but
um I'm afraid he gives a unique insight
into the way government works and how
the government handled the pandemic I
wouldn't like to be in the position of
having turned it away do you have any
qualms at all as journalists regarding
the the the ethics and I understand the
argument about the public interest and
you'll run it past lawyers given the NDA
and so on but any crimes at all
ethically as journalists
about
a journalist
you know signing a non-disclosure
agreement with somebody who was writing
a book in exchange for having access to
you know very very personal details I
mean I'm not sure I know anyone who'd
like all their WhatsApp messages to be
put all over the front page of the Daily
Telegraph even you know if they are you
know highly reputable individuals but
um do you have any qualms about it at
all
and I suppose in terms of our inquiry
does it in any way undermine trust in
journalists that actually it doesn't
matter what they say to you at the end
of the day if it's a good story you're
screwed
uh well first of all there were aspects
of it that I would have had qualms about
and one is
um
publishing Matt Hancock's whatsapps
maybe one thing because he he he had
given them to Isabel oakshot to write a
book with the intention of him being
painted in in a heroic light and
um so there seems to me to be a pretty
strong public interest in knowing the
truth about what he is saying
um I did feel for Helen waitley I think
it was the junior Minister because
they published everybody else's
whatsapps as well
um and I would be fascinated to hear
what people like Ellen Whiteley or Simon
case or other people involved think
about this
um
I mean I can illustrate this by a story
from my own time as editor which also
involves Isabel Oak shot and we were
approached through an intermediary by
Vicky price the wife of Chris Hoon about
her allegations about her taking his
speeding points
she quite understandably didn't want to
go to prison
and we spent weeks on the mail on Sunday
with lawyers trying to find a way of
doing this that wouldn't end up with her
being prosecuted
she got impatient went to Isabel oakshop
and Isabelle Oak shot then working for
the Sunday Times published the next week
and Vicky Bryce went to prison
she did indeed I I knew her when she was
Economist when I was a minister in the
business department she was our chief
Economist at the time but I lost the
story yeah so there we go I can't answer
that one any qualms any of the rest of
you
basically about this I think there are
qualms about other people's text
messages but
what's that but I think you could
probably have done the story in such a
way that you didn't necessarily have to
use all of those but I think there is a
public interest justification for
journalism and
and I think that that in this situation
that's okay so you don't think it
undermines trust in journalists that
what this whole episode I think it's
this is quite a specific evidence that
episode in that you've got a very high
profile politician in the biggest story
of Our Generation giving his WhatsApp
messages to a very high profile
journalist so I think there are other
things that you could say cause distrust
in journalists I don't think this is one
of them this is just what happens when a
conceited fool gives their WhatsApp
messages to a devious Scribbler
basically is that what you're saying
that's what you just said
David you could say that I can't comment
yeah I mean I I take a similar view I
mean I
um somebody takes me last week and said
is this a breach of confidentiality and
I said it's probably a breach of
confidence more than that and I think
there is a difference there he as Peter
said he used this WhatsApp Trove to
write the book I know you've seen the
rest of the context I I don't think
there's much of a complaint on his part
apart from with
um the person who'd made the agreement
with
um but I I think there is a strong
public interest and then the other
aspect is if you're in public life be
careful what you're committing to uh to
communication which again is is uh is
challenging and and I think we all have
to navigate our way through that
um
just just on
um briefly sorry I think it was just on
it was just following on from what what
uh um
my colleague has just been asking
questions about which is about Elizabeth
vote shot authoring uh that book for um
ghost writes in that book I mean is that
given given what you've seen of the
what's in the whatsapps
do you think that book should be
Rewritten is it a trusted source of
information
as a journalist full story is it but
then but it's not the full story but I
guess most people's biographies aren't
they aren't there in the full story of
their life their life as they perceive
it the journalist wrote it ghost wrote
it
in full possession of all those
whatsapps
I mean and we can now see what was
written compare what was written what
what we now know I mean you'd have to
get into what the arrangement was around
ghost writing a book ordinarily a ghost
writer
uses all the info and then the actual
person who should have been writing the
book in the first place edits it so that
they feel that's uh so I don't know that
you could necessarily blame the
journalist in that scenario it's the
person whose name's on the front cover
you could probably call it Matt Hancock
my version of events yes
reconstructed diary after the facts
wasn't it you know but but um can I just
ask one on one other issue uh briefly
chair and that is
um you know on the legacy of levison and
hacking and so on
um
how much damage did that do to your
organizations or to you know trust in
journalism and and newspapers and media
organizations and is there still a
legacy of it I mean are there you know
are you still facing challenges about it
and and and and enhance the response
from the industry post levison
um actually worked I mean just just
thoughts on that and I will start with
you this Sunday
um so obviously I mean our organization
has been throughout a huge amount of
turmoil as a result of it the news the
world as you know closed uh as a result
of it
um we have uh I the industry as a whole
is almost an unrecognizable from what it
was a decade ago uh in the way that uh
it operates and it's uh the way that it
goes about its business and I have every
confidence in the way that a certainly
our titles and the evidence I see from
other papers that um uh we conduct our
business in a in a fit and proper
fashion and I think it's really
important to understand when you uh
Allison was talking about you know how
we go about verifying a story
we as news Brands we train journalists
we pay journalists we
bring in lawyers we pay lawyers we have
a an editor's code of conduct which if
you haven't read it I would
um I would implore you to do so because
I think it's an excellent document and
an excellent guide which when I was
editing newspapers I certainly lived by
an unsure
um my colleagues do the same that's just
pre-publication post-publication you
have the uh the right of redress you can
go to the title itself you can go to IPS
or you can go to the courts there are
many ways in which you can deal with
um with complaints to newspapers that
you just have no chance with in social
media I don't go into it because I think
John Nicholson might ask a question
about that later but and I so what
you're saying in essence is
we've completely changed our practices
as a result of that Scandal and that
what's remaining there are some Legacy
cases I think still coming through the
courts that we can't talk about there's
a subject to say presumably but that's
the position we're in currently is that
is that a fair assessment situation and
does anybody want to add anything to
that from the perspective of your own
organizations how it's impacted and
whether it's still impacting upon you
I think religious as David said I just
think everything has changed everything
has changed and the way we operate is
entirely different and that's a good
thing and
we are sort of on that kind of
process of trying to rebuild Trust
me I mean the guardian broke the story
as you know as you know but that doesn't
mean that we felt that we were excused
for a more exempt from examining our own
processes and
we have this reader's editor that we've
had now for 25 years and
it's been a sort of fantastic recourse
for people who
have a complaint against uh journalism
and you know it's something that kath is
cathayna Catherine our editor-in-chief
has emphasized time and again since
she's editor is that um we can't
we can't assume trust we have to earn it
okay and final question to you Peter
what do you think of these this
development of things like talk TV and
GB news and so on and what implications
it has for for your organizations
organizations traditionally printed
newspapers and have operated under
different rules than broadcast media and
and what's happening in that space now
is it a good development is it a
concerning development I mean I'm I'm
afraid I'm not a consumer of GB news or
talk TV
um I
I mean the
the sort of informal state of play which
developed over the years once television
came on the scene was that television
operated under state license
um
and the trade-off was that it had State
regulation and that part of that
regulation was a requirement for
impartiality and
certainly going back decades that that
sort of was reasonably true of BBC and
ITV
and newspapers and when I came into
newspapers I was told I was an idiot
because newspapers were dead this was
1974.
because we couldn't compete with TV well
we did
um and
um that Arrangement left
field for newspapers
to provide comment and opinion and
campaign and to take up causes in a way
that TV found much more difficult
um
now
I I can't pretend to know David will
know better than me how oftcom is
applying impartiality rules
to GB news and talk TV
and again David will know the size of
their audiences they don't seem to me to
be vast but
[Music]
um
if if
television had a free hand with opinion
and didn't have to to obey impartiality
rules um
then I presume life for newspapers would
would get more more difficult I'm not
going to harm any more time I'll hand
back to you chair and uh
thank you thank you chair
um so first of all Alison um to give
David a break from being the first
um
you said earlier that uh medical people
were the trusted voices during the
pandemic
um and uh but then there was a big
campaign on social media who said that
they weren't to be trusted and even uh
poor Chris witty was physically attacked
as a result of some of that uh
campaigning uh shouldn't you as as
mainstream media and this is really for
all of you but Alison first of all uh
feel a responsibility to push back
against such campaigns or do you just
report on them
um well I mean I think we did push back
I think we all pushed back but not in a
not in a
you've got to explain the news to people
you can't just batter them over the head
with it our responsibility is to to
explain and that's why we try to focus
on the importance of good information
and
um and to give people the
sort of information that they needed so
that if you imagine you're at work and
you're having an argument with somebody
who's just got all their information off
of a WhatsApp group or off of a a
posting that they've seen you've got to
give them the the ability to fight back
say no no because I read in the mirror
this that and the other thing so that's
how we do it there is no point in
anybody just going out there and yelling
at people that they're stupid and
they're thick because that does not
change people's minds and also that make
might make them become even more
entrenched I suppose yeah and I don't
know whether how much of that I mean I
guess you're looking at it how much of
that misinformation you were seeing
um interestingly I because of Prior
WhatsApp groups I was in because my
children's sport and things like that I
was seeing all these WhatsApp messages
coming in and it'd be things like oh
another football is just collapsed
because of having had the jab and then
and and so that's when we talk about
trusted news people trust people they
know so if one of the dads in your kids
football team said oh this is that's
that's how you have that relationship of
trust because it's somebody that you
know so the media obviously is that bit
a part and that's why we have to have
those relationships with our readers
that they feel that we're like friends
who are telling them some good
information yeah um so this committee
has in in the previous Incarnation
taking evidence
um on how social media gives a big voice
to um small and perhaps extreme and and
often um uninformed opinions
um and and that that can be a very
dangerous thing and so so do we look to
you the mainstream media to make sure
you're giving that voice of truth but
how do you make sure I know you've
covered it to a certain extent how do
you ensure that you can get that message
through to those people who are getting
their news from their trusted source
which is the person they know who has
been misinformed by social media if you
see what I mean well I remember we
certainly do yeah when when people were
attached attacking 5G phone masts we
certainly did a number of expose on the
people behind
these crazy series and and debunking
them
um
but I mean it it's a
you
it's worth doing when something is
actually causing clear damage
you're always aware of the risk that
by giving someone
publicity even if it's negative
publicity there are going to be people
who believe it it's not easy no no there
is that thing of course you mustn't give
them oxygen so don't comment um uh well
also you know you've only got limited
resources and
um really they should be devoted to
covering events that have actually
happened
and you know science that is science not
not bogus science absolutely but there
comes a point where you do need to
debunk it yeah this one's for Nick
really um do you think there's a a
responsibility responsibility on
newspapers such as the guardian to to
um spread calm amongst the Panic we've
got to look through it of the lens of
the time we didn't know what was coming
we've iterated that today and and and
the government the scientists were
literally feeling their way because we
didn't know what was happening
um and it would be easy on social media
to spread panic or was there a
Temptation in the media and I'm not
accusing any any uh publication
represented here
um to trade on the sort of the Penny
Dreadful side of things because horror
and shock is much more interesting
um no I don't think so I mean I think
that we took a view all the way through
the pandemic that we would
um as I said to announce the previous
questions we would try and wrap around
our news stories context
and Analysis and FAQs and devices such
as that where which would allow our
journalists to
hopefully in an honest and transparent
way explain the state of knowledge of
that particular moment in time and what
we didn't and as I said earlier these
were those kinds of pieces were the ones
that really did fantastically well
during
the pandemic people wanted to to to be
told
in as much detail as we could
um in as accessible
ways we possibly could what was going on
at any given moment well that's
encouraging so you didn't feel like you
were shouting at a wall of a blankness
nobody listening they were listening to
Social Media instead no I mean I mean
yes the other panelists have have said I
mean there is a big problem wider
problem which is are hopefully trusted
news
online can be mingled with
misinformation but in terms of
you know our job is just to make sure
that the material we produce is is as
honest and trustworthy as possible and
go to those places like Tick Tock we do
stuff on Tick Tock now and even if
they're not even if the readers the
people who use tick tock are not
necessarily
Guardian readers Now by going into there
to that Community they may they may the
gravitational pull hopefully of our
journalism will bring them towards us
very helpful you've touched on something
I want to ask next
um your editorial code at the guardian
says that trust in the authenticity and
reliability of our sources is sensual
and it's those very sources I wanted to
ask about
um
and and they will move along the ball
but initially to Nick again uh do your
newspapers put more weight on Anonymous
sources or or those who are willing to
be identified
well with you know the code states that
we mustn't use anonymous sources lazily
or indiscriminately I think is the words
that we use
um I mean do we use anonymous sources
yes we do
but
um we would
we would take using Anonymous sources on
a kind of case-by-case basis
and and also it to a degree it depends
on the journalists who's offering the
story if someone like um Pippa Carrera
who Alison does very well
tells us she has anonymous source in
Whitehall who is telling her something
um you know Pippa has fantastic reach
into the corridors of power
so um we would listen to her it wouldn't
it wouldn't mean that we wouldn't
interrogate her on it
if it's more Junior reporter is offering
a story based on anonymous source then
we would probably
um question them on the caution and
we'll find out
yeah it's it's I'm sure that every
politician in the room has been asked by
a journalist to give a quote off the
Record and that's probably where some of
these sources come from but uh um do you
think that the use
of anonymous sources might lower the
Trust In journalism
well obviously you don't want to use
anonymous sources unless you really have
to you want to be able to put a name and
a title and a responsibility to the
source that you're quoting that is not
always
possible
um
so you know ideally we wouldn't have to
use them but there are circumstances in
which in which we do and fundamentally
if a story is right it's right
and and if we use an anonymous source
and we as Alison has said we go to
somebody for a Rite of reply and in that
right of reply it becomes very clear
that whatever the source has told us is
correct then that shouldn't diminish
The credibility of that kind of story
okay any other comments on this
no okay fair enough so I'll ask one more
question so we all recall I'm sure David
Sullivan's publication Sunday sport uh
daily Sport and and the general public
knew that um fundamentally what was
published there was rubbish Elvis had
been found on the Dark Side of the Moon
Hitler was somewhere or whatever it was
and we all knew it was rubbish and uh
and and quite rightly purported as the
precursor to uh social media stories how
much damage do you think that did
because that was a paper publication
there's The Beano I mean I don't know I
don't know
exactly exactly but people did believe
it did they I don't think anybody I
think it was pure yeah okay fair enough
fair enough you never sold very many
copies I think the important thing to
remember is that you
people and again the stats Builder so
that most people when they read
something on social media they will then
go and check it in uh you know
a reputable news source and I think we
still play a really important role in
that sort of verification process in
back in the Sunday sport days you
described that as an urban myth and as
editors of papers we could just ignore
it now there's such a low barrier to
entry to the distribution of information
these things take on a life of their own
so it may be and when we move into the
world of deep fakes which is on us now
and stay sponsored this information
it may be that we do need to start
showing why we are not running stories
and these are the reasons why they are
not true again you bring me neatly onto
my next question on what basis do you
decide whether to publish stories about
misinformation and disinformation
it's I have a good example of this and
at Christmas I was um I was with a
friend who I'm not going to embarrass by
identifying her but she has a senior
public affairs role at a multinational
con company and we're talking about the
zelenskis and Mrs zelensken particular
and she said well it was such a shame
that she went and spent forty thousand
dollars on a handbag and shoe spree in
Paris and I literally felt the bottom
fall out of my stomach and I this is
this is horrific and I thought but it
can't be true and I went home and I
investigated it and the first hit on
Google was a Newsweek debunking
of their story which had emanated from
the Sunderland Global media
one in one employee Anna back over so
you know it that is a good example of
Attraction when it did get traction yeah
it get traction all over France all over
the states
to the point where it had to be debunked
and I think that's the the point we
can't be the policeman of the internet
no but we can be a source of trust do
you have any concerns that actually
covering these sort of stories actually
gives them some credence no I think in
in in cases like that where you're able
to go there is no evidence to support
this whatsoever I think that is
important and and in the Deep fake thing
as well where you'll have you know a
video of something going around Twitter
if you're able to say this is
categorically not true and that's coming
from one of our organizations then that
will really help is there any liaison
between the organizations news
organizations on this if something comes
along that is damaged you speak to each
other team
I mean reporters may do
um it's informal it's being informal yes
um you know it wouldn't be appropriate
but discussing what stories we're doing
okay thank you no thank you
but all I would say is that um if you
look at any MPS email inbox the idea
that everyone goes away and checks uh
with a reputable news source before they
they get convinced by something they've
read online I'm afraid that's not true
but I agree we may get a skewed uh
section of the population John Nichols
thank you very much yes on that I'm just
looking here at the story that just
popped up from the herald on Sunday and
it is Kate Forbes who's one of the
candidates for the SNP leadership with a
Bible photoshopped into her hand that
can't be right okay front page she
wasn't holding a Bible she was just
standing like that and if photoshopped a
Bible into her hand because
um she has some controversial uh
religious views
um can I start off with with you uh
Peter I was interested that you talked
about the straightforward uh coverage
that that Metro uh got and by some
metrics local papers have higher trust
levels don't they than some of the
Nationals what do you think the
Nationals have got to learn from local
coverage straight forward coverage as
you described it
uh well I mean as I said earlier I I
think one of the reasons why locals have
higher trust levels is simply that you
you can observe for yourself what
they've reported which you can't do
with national papers
um
the way the newspaper Market has evolved
in Britain has meant that unlike in the
US or in France or Germany where most
titles are defined geographically under
local monopolies
um
um the the national newspaper Market in
Britain has divided demographically and
politically
um that may be the key people feel with
local papers that they're not being spun
aligned that stories aren't being
filtered but the newspapers politics and
that in fact they're being told news the
truth rather rather than political spin
it's not so much the truth and local
paper a matter of the truth and local
papers do run leaders or they certainly
did in in my day and they do run
campaigns and they do like take
political positions and
um
but
it uh
I mean I think all our titles took a
position one way or another over brexit
Metro didn't
um but the Daily Mail was in favor of
brexit Mel on Sunday was against
um
you know
everybody took a position and readers
expect
the position
um to reinforce their own prejudices
uh well readers I mean opinions are
valuable
um I mean people want to know facts but
they understand that you also want to
know opinions you don't just want to be
told that the economy is in a nosedive
you know the cost of living's gone up 12
in the last month uh you want to know
why that's happened which will be 50
opinion because there'll be different
theories and you want to know what could
be done about it
and that inevitably is going to be
opinion I mean economists will all give
you different answers
yeah I think I'm mostly pretty much
agree that brexit's been pretty
disastrous that's what they'll be our
says but but but well that's your
opinion well that's what the obr says
and I'm not um I'm not responsible for
what the obr says I I've um I've asked
people online to tell me what questions
uh they would like asked I'm very keen
on the whistleblowers actually and I
quite often encourage them to write uh
to me here and you get some fantastic
stuff you've got to filter it very
carefully of course to make sure that
people are really who they imply that
they are
one of the questions I've been asked
quite a lot is what responsibility uh
you as newspapers have to promote
trusted voices in other words how
engaged are you in making sure that what
you say is true
Allison
um
well we aim to ensure that everything we
Prince is true
um
by your description three layers of
editorial oversight I think you
mentioned it's probably more than three
by the time you've gone through all
those different sets of eyes I mean
mistakes happen we try to avoid mistakes
happening what was the last big mistake
you made
um gosh I think we've been all right for
a few months but um but I mean we do but
but mistakes will happen in any
organization so our role is to but in
terms of actual premeditated attempts to
mislead people there's absolutely none
of that and in terms of trusted voices
we have many voices
both in terms of people doing sort of
straight news and also opinion writers
who our readers trust now you may not or
other people may not agree with what
they say and so therefore they're
perhaps less likely to trust those
people but our readers trust them and
that's why they're there and I I think
going back to your point about local
news why do people feel that local news
is more trustworthy quite often I think
that might be because you're less likely
to read something in a local paper or
Local website that you disagree with and
I think if you go into that whole
situation about polarization within that
Society there is a tendency now that if
people don't agree with a particular
Viewpoint they find it untrustworthy and
I think if you're unpicking this whole
issue you need to have a look at that
that's social media that's done that
I think we as a society brexit had a
huge impact on us I think social media I
think the way the algorithms work I
think are such that it's it's easier to
sow descend than it is to sow issues
that bring people back together
um I think the social media algorithms
are a huge issue in this
I love
pick up a pile from the Sun to the
guardian I I like talk old newspapers
um and I'm interested that's a a
generational thing which is which is
probably a little bit
um which is probably a little bit sad
but I like to read them online as well
um can I perhaps turn Nick to talk to
you which is something else a lot of
people have asked me about which is
about corrections
now I know you've not signed up for
episode maybe we can explain to people
that there are there are two Regulators
there's the one that the industry wanted
which is episode and then there's a
another one which is which is
independent and that wasn't really
delivered after Levinson or politicians
promised at the time was there but ipso
only upholds a tiny number of complaints
uh am I right
and you might well be but we're not a
member of ipso I know we have our own
separate checks and balances
systems it's like not to join them so
well I mean this is all quite historic
arguments but if you could just remember
this is for for late people to to I
think um so if you could explain it
quite some posts after levison
um my recollection is that we we thought
that ipso was
um a a slightly better but still quite
similar to The Press complaints
commission
um and so it really wasn't our cup of
tea I don't think our view has changed
since then and as I recall leverson
um praised the checks and balances
system that the guardian had at the time
which have been reinforced since then
with the reader's editor role which
we've had for a long time now so we've
We've Ended up in a in the position
we're in and we're comfortable with it
and certainly from from what surveys
they have been done we're regarded as a
trusted news source what would you need
episode to do to persuade you to join
episode
as head of news it's not a subject that
I'm I sort of grapple with day to day
I'm sure I could get you uh journalists
talk about it I know just one whack said
you're more likely to win euromillions
than you are to get episode to force you
to to publish an apology at the same
size and in the same prominence as the
original article of the Articles untrue
I guess one of the things that we were
worried about at the time is the sort of
it's the
is the perception of total Independence
so and I and I think at the time that
ipso is being set up we weren't
comfortable
with it we at the absor in a previous
committee lips are high Heaton in front
of us
um a supreme boss
um who was astonished to discover that
newspapers might print retractions in
smaller lettering than the original
story and he shared with the committee
his
surprise and that he felt he'd been
slightly misled on this I think I'm
right in saying that episode have not
once since it was founded required a
front page apology of equal prominence
to the story itself which had ruled was
inaccurate
again you know that's really not for me
to just be a little bit
counter-intuitive because you're not a
source I thought I'd ask you about some
of these
um now another thing uh David that
people have asked and every politician
will talk about is stories that they
himself themselves have been involved
with which they think are are unfair now
I was interested
um in what you said earlier and I wrote
it down you said that you have every
confidence
that your newspapers your titles conduct
business and in effect and proper uh
fashion and I think Allison said that
flat denials were always taken into
account now
of all the stories I've been involved in
and I'm a journalist by by training so I
know how to research a story but of all
the stories I've been involved in since
I was fresh elected to Parliament in in
2015 one of them stands out to me and it
was a story that was in the sun and it
Bears a a little
um reprise um which was my office got a
package sent to
it was white crystals we followed
parliamentary procedure we phoned
parliamentary security they called the
police the police closed down the
streets and evacuated the offers
the person concerned I understand was
subsequently arrested
um the police asked me not to talk to
journalists about what they discovered
the sun journalist called me up and he
said who was in the package and I said I
can't tell you the police have asked me
not to say
the sun journalist said
was it a biscuit
of course it wasn't a Biscuit the police
aren't good to close down a street for a
biscuit obviously and I got to the
particles down the streets obviously
it's a place who've done that and the
sun journalist said so that was a catech
Oracle denial I said categorical denial
so this was the story that the sun then
published all crumbs suspicious package
which caused major lockdown around SNP
MP's office turns out to be a biscuit
not given a categorical denial the
journalist knewed was untrue the jealous
knew that an MP cannot close down a
street
and the journalists must have known that
was untrue but let me tell you what the
consequence of that is
first of all the story is still on the
sun's website
years later
I got trolled for days and days and
weeks and weeks with people telling me I
was an idiot I'd wasted this time I'd
close down a street for a biscuit I'd
destroyed the livelihood of shops
operating uh there
um I mean at some levels you could say
that was
funny but a lot of people believed it
and at the end of the day
I had my office had actually been sent
something
that was potentially dangerous there
were crystals that the police taught me
could be used to make an explosive
device
does a newspaper go through that would
result in that story being published and
remain online years afterwards despite
clearly everyone involved I mean it's
false
what
steps did you take after publication
to get it removed from online uh I spoke
to senior executive yeah at the at the
sun about it
um I explained that it was untrue I'd
already spoken to the journalist and
Sarah and then told them that it was
untrue
everybody involved in knew that it was
untrue I I was left feeling that it was
probably a a deliberate attempt
from and newspaper that isn't
sympathetic to the SNP to spread a bit
of disinformation and it disappointed me
because I've got great respect for the
sun's journalism one of my close friends
is Gene Moore as a star columnist for
the sun I love reading her columns so I
was just I was disappointed in it but it
you didn't go to episode you didn't
pursue it further I I didn't go to the
independent regulator because I don't
have much faith in the independent
regulator and then this is a this is a
this is a huge Splash at what episode
would have gotten is in page 12 I put a
tiny little box saying that it was onto
and the coffee if it was untrue right
and of course it was untrue the place
Dental is down the street
we haven't been able to investigate it
right I'm hearing about this now so if
it was untrue and you went to ipso ipso
would have gone straight to the to the
Sun said this is the version of events
from you uh what's your defense on this
they would have got to a resolution I
suspect if your version is correct there
would have been a correction would have
been taken down online and that would
have
a matter of hours or days yes and we
would not be sitting here today with it
still online and that is there for every
member of the public
David the obvious one is
it might be taken down online although I
I complained to a senior executive who
told me that it would be and it hasn't
been and I didn't realize that until
yesterday and I can discuss the specific
case because I don't know the specific
case secondly because the newspaper has
been published it's in every new stand
in the country you can't take that back
um and you can't do more as a politician
than give a categorical denial to a
journalist and also rely on the
journalists common sense because the
journalist knows that the police will
not examine a package see a couple of
Kit Kats and close down the streets so
as a journalist you as a journalist we
know that that would not happen
which as I say I find disappointing as
as a journalist as somebody who admires
uh the son's
um uh professionalism and um I just
thought I'd flag that up because it was
one particular example that I I've come
across when I went from portrait to Game
Keeper and moved from journalism into
politics well I'd say I mean and thank
you for doing so but I'd say that the
the courses of redress are there
exceptions you accept that once the
newspaper is out the damage to me is
already been done the best that you
could have offered me if I'd gone
through epsil would have been a
retraction
sometime afterwards in much smaller
lettering inside the newspaper the fact
that it appeared in the paper there's no
way of undoing that afterwards it would
it would like it would likely appear in
the same place
appeared in the first place it would
have I don't know where it appeared in
the paper very prominently and my point
remains that there hasn't been a single
example of any story ever getting the
same prominence
have been front page apologies which is
since since not in the same not not not
the same degree of prominence I would
agree with that but there has been front
page apologies and I'm not sure you can
you know that's that's a a significant
uh move forward
thank you
um one last sort of quick question for
to each of you and I'll start at the
other end just to be fair to David
um you've all had long distinguished
careers that have led you to the the top
of of Journalism
um do you think that trust in newspapers
and their websites is higher or lower
than when you started out in your
careers
I'm not sure uh it was so long ago I
started out sure I'm not sure anybody
was measuring it then
um
it it it's always going to be difficult
being journalists for for a number of
reasons one one is that you're reporting
events as they happen and
um you there will always be different
versions and different interpretations
of what you report
um and that will always affect people's
view of you as a as a professional
um I think
um
if
trust is declined particularly in recent
years it may be because
some of the big stories of recent years
have been very divisive ones where
um I'm thinking particularly if brexit
or covid as well in a way where people
have have been divided within families
in their opinions
and where people don't want to believe
what they perceive to be
contradictory to their point of view and
therefore
there's a shoot that the messenger
attitude
um and there's actually an illustration
of that in
um
the um
the Reuters Research
into trust Recent research which
found that over the last three years
trust in the BBC which normally scores
very highly had fallen about 75 to 55
percent
and they ascribed that to a working
class viewers
disagreeing with the BBC's line on on
brexit and therefore not trusting the
reporting with that's their observation
not mine but so
so that that's interesting I also I'm
afraid to think there's the phenomenon
where people across whether they trust
in news but as I mentioned earlier they
may actually be talking about what they
read on Tick Tock rather than
what they what what comes from an outfit
like I saw the mirror or the guardian
all the times but basically lower it's
quite that's quite a pessimistic
analysis you can say there are reasons
for it but but trust has gone down uh
I'm not I'm not sure that it that it has
um the
um I think the
ofcom research shows it has in recent
years but they don't go back very far
but um
okay yeah I mean if we could raise trust
it would be great
um I
have a worthiness of
the established news organizations has
actually increased hugely to when I
think back to sort of maybe the mid-80s
um
so I think the quality
of the content that people are getting
now is is is is far more informative and
responsible and well thought through and
I'm not just saying that because I'm in
this role now but I think if you looked
back to some of the particularly sort of
like the sun in the mirror at that
period and compare with it with the
reporting that goes on today I think
it's hugely improved however
I think we can't just look at sort of
lack of trust in the media in isolation
I think it's something that every major
institution in the country is
is facing the police politicians
um doctors so as a society we've changed
enormously I mean my grandparents
generation used to talk about their
betters you know if a doctor told them
this is what you had that is what you
had now people will go in and they'll
question that just they'll question the
police no question journalists so and
you can argue that a lot of that's good
because people are becoming much more
questioning and skeptical about the
world around them but that obviously
comes with a breakdown in trust so how
much of that is caused by social media
and all the changes that I think
probably a lot of it is but I think it's
just there's all sorts of other sort of
socioeconomic reasons that probably feed
into that as well so
but I think to put some good news in
there as well if you look I think all
the people here on this table during
covid we saw record numbers of people
coming to us for the content that we
were creating we saw print sales holding
up when you weren't barely allowed out
the front door and that is because
people really wanted news they could
trust at that point and they knew that
they established news organizations in
this country were places they could get
it so yes there was bad stuff happening
in some places as well but there was
still a real hunger for trusted news and
we were able to fulfill that so
um I think
I think you can't look at us in
isolation I think if there is less trust
in us that's because there's less trust
in most things now in this country
I think it Ebbs and flows you know uh as
as Alison has said I think um
uh
covid the whole pandemic
um I think most news organizations
um you know behave really responsibly
and I think our readers reacted to that
and our readership stored and
um and I think that's
we we showed that we could be trusted
during a time of
um of panic and emergency to to provide
trusted information I also think that
you know I actually feel quite I feel
quite hopeful when I when I think about
you know the the
the scandals in public life that have
been brought to light by journalists
whether it's Barnard Castle or partygate
or any one of the investigations the
guardian's done in recent years I mean
people really react to them you know
they they will come to us and subscribe
to us they write to us and they tell us
they want more of it and our readership
goes up so
you know I feel I feel
hopeful that um that in the future
we can sustain the sort of The Trusted
voice
that um
that people relied on from us during the
pandemic
yeah I'm similarly bullish because I
think
um you know the the world in which we
live has changed I evolve recognition
last 20 25 years
um the speed of information we're now
dealing on a second by second basis and
we've had to evolve to to kind of meet
that that need but I think the need for
professional media professional
journalism has never been greater
because there has never been more
information out there somebody's got to
make sense of it somebody has got to
provide the the raw material in the
first place and there is no one apart
from us really doing that job so
actually I think uh I think the future
is is bright
um and it is it is important that we
have a vibrant National media and local
media in this country
which will only uh enhance democracy and
Trust at the same time
okay thank you all very much indeed for
your time and insight this morning David
Dinsmore thank you thank you very much
that concludes our session order order